it's time for another segment of
designed by
drew where we get to create a brand new
space for incredible people
and today's design by drew viewer thinks
she's here for some design advice
and has no idea that we actually have a
brand new room
waiting for her behind those doors
okay first let's meet the mom
whose strength and positivity are truly
inspiring take a look
[Music]
my name is karen mckechnie i live in
scarborough maine
i have two little boys jack and drew who
are six and nine years old
i met ian we were both 22 years old
and within about an hour so i knew he
was the one
and i leaned over and whispered in my
friend's ear this is the guy i'm gonna
marry
[Music]
the happiest that ian and i have ever
been was
that summer when we first moved into our
house in scarborough
it's our dream home and we put in a lot
of love
into pretty much every single room
except for
our master bedroom our thought was
that's the only room that nobody goes in
but us
so let's put all our time and effort and
money into the rest of the house
we knew we needed to buy some new
decorative items
and kind of spruce place up making our
own and so i went to christmas tree shop
being on the tight budget i was on
and so i came home with this sailboat
painting and i said ian
someday my bedroom will match this
painting and this will work on the walls
in there and it will go and he was like
okay
all right someday not now but i agree
someday
one of the happiest days of our lives
was the day that drew was born
but it was the day after that in the
hospital that ian's mom looked at him
and said
your coloring looks off it just it looks
different and i think you should go get
it checked out and he was diagnosed with
lyme
sarcoma his reaction was always okay
so what do i do next no chemo scared him
no surgery he just wanted to know what
was next he wanted
to beat it and he wanted to beat it
because he had two little boys at home
and he had me and he had this whole life
ahead of us i remember saying goodbye to
ian
when i had to bring him to the hospice
house and i knew he was never going to
come back to this house
and i remember saying to him
we painted every wall we've done
everything to this house together
you will always be in this house with us
ian is a part of our life every single
day
everything's daddy this daddy that we
have photo montage videos of him that my
kids will say
friday night instead of a movie can we
watch daddy's video
and we have a lot of fun there's no way
i can waste this life that jack and drew
and i have together
on not being happy and enjoying
everything we get to see and everything
we get to experience
it's hard but i can't not do that for
him
[Applause]
um okay uh
why and how do you know that positivity
really is
an answer for you or could be an answer
for anyone
i don't think there's really any other
option um
life short things happen that you have
no idea
you don't know what tomorrow is going to
bring so i
i live every day knowing that
a lot of bad can happen whether it's
cancer whether it's covid
life can change on a whirlwind and uh
staying positive and trying to be the
best person you can be and be happy
why not like why would you not want to
do that right
i couldn't agree more
like when a choice doesn't seem easy
that day
what do you turn to to go
and get back to that positivity yeah for
me
honestly it's that ian doesn't even have
that choice anymore
and i have these two little boys who
were four and six when their dad passed
away and their dad
is and always will be and should be
their hero
and i live every day and there's
there's things i get to see and
experience and do and laugh and have fun
and
ian would give anything to do those
things
with us and watching someone go through
cancer
to watch someone who is saying okay
what's next okay i'll do that chemo sure
i'll try that surgery
how can i how can i not now live and be
like of course i'm going to have fun
like
he made these horrible choices just
because he wanted to be able to have fun
and continue to have fun someday
i i'm able i'm healthy i'm able to
have that fun with jack and drew and you
know
show them that life can be really hard
and it's just about looking at what you
can change
what you can be in control of and
finding the positives being happy and
being kind
i know in honoring your home
you know you've taken care of the kids
spaces
and you've you know fixed up everything
and
done your little things and you've left
this bedroom
sort of as a last step and
i would imagine that changing the
bedroom
probably has a lot of emotional ties to
it as well now
like is there any conflict or does it
seem like
okay it's time what's the what is going
on in you what's your inner dialogue
yeah so
2020 was like kind of a turning point
for me going into 2020
and at the beginning of the year his
clothes were still
everywhere my closet was half my clothes
half his clothes
and i finally i think it was after covet
hit where it was like you know we're all
now in our homes and kind of analyzing
and thinking about our lives even in a
deeper level right
and it was sort of like i think i'm
ready to
put these away they're in the basement
in bins they're they're not going
anywhere
but they're not in my bedroom so that
was my first big step
and then next has been okay i gotta get
rid of the stripes
my my yeah i've now at the point where i
think in
i know that ian wants me to be happy and
i think that any positive thing that
happens
to me and the kids i do believe that he
can
see me i think he sees us
i choose to believe that i have to
believe that that he sees all the things
that jack and drew do and that i do
and uh i think he'd be really happy and
ready that i'm now mentally in a place
where i can say
okay i can make this what i what we
always wanted it to be
it goes along with the whole 2020 for me
moving forward and making these strides
that i really wasn't able to do
he passed away in 2018 i wasn't able to
do that until i all of a sudden
was and that's okay i think it's just
incredibly healthy and i'd be honored to
discuss it with you
i live for design i've heard that and i
think that sounds amazing
i'll take any advice i can get perfect
and i know where your heart is at so
we're going to do this respectfully and
thought
you